has trained too many young minds like
yours to forget about that
our Constantine Bravo I can see why 50
million people plus are watching that
because I think it gives some of us hope
that maybe the tide is starting to turn
on this madness what's your take yeah
and I think also the reason people
enjoyed it as well is I'm actually
challenging these young people to be
better right I think you know and and I
that we've all spoken about the problems
with World culture and the many problems
but I think what we have to start to
think about is how do we get beyond that
and we're going to need these kids
they're going to be paying our pensions
40 years from now or whenever it is and
we need them to step up if you know the
entire speech I talk about climate
change which is an issue they really
care about if you care about it that
means you have to work you have to find
Technical Solutions and and that's what
I think we have to start getting to
rather than just focusing on what's
wrong with workness I think we all know
what's wrong with workness at this point
we have to start thinking about how do
we encourage young people to be better
to be more resilient mentally and so on
yeah and it's hard for them though isn't
it Constantine because as much as I
criticize them they are now growing up
in a culture where they are told right
from a very young age not only is it
okay to be a victim actually it's
sometimes a preferable thing to be to be
a victim to sort of wallow in victimhood
exactly and I think that's where we as
adults have to step in and go actually
you know if you want to make something
of yourself because look the reality is
young people do want to get on in life
and make something of themselves the
victimhood is not going to be the way
you achieve that and make quite a lot of
them have never heard that message
before so one of the interesting things
about it was talking to the students
afterwards at the Oxford Union and there
were quite a lot of them who were how
did it go down did they did they like
what you had I think some of them liked
what I had to say but the interesting
thing is there were quite a few people
who came up to me and said you know what
I was very skeptical but actually it was
an interesting speech and it made me
think and I think that's the sort of
thing that we have to start thinking
about is what is our positive vision for
these uh young people and for our own
children and you know our generation
their generation I think we've been
badly let down by actually previous
generations who haven't told us what is
the way to actually think about things
and what is the way to live life I agree
but I also think people have to make
individual choices don't they and I
think if you look at uh my history or
your history for example uh neither of
us were born with the silver spoon in
our mouth we also were not born in this
country the odds were against us you
could say and there are lots of things
that I could talk about where people
might think I'm a victim but I refuse to
do so it's not that I don't want to
share myself because I'm actually very
open person but it's because I refuse to
be one of those people who walks around
being a victim I think actually one of
the worst things about woke culture is
sometimes it's all about focusing on the
past and it's not about actually working
out about how you can use the tough
obstacles in life to actually make
something I couldn't agree with you more
Dan and that's why I think that is the
message that we should be sharing with
people is look 20 years ago I was
sleeping in a park in Edinburgh because
I couldn't afford rent right and here I
am now I've got a Sunday Times
best-selling book I've got a very
successful YouTube show and that is the
beauty of the West as you know I talk
about it in my book you have the
opportunity to make something of
yourself you've done it I've done it and
there are plenty of people watching this
who are maybe young and maybe haven't
had the opportunity to do that well
guess what you live in a country one of
very few countries in the world where
you can come from nothing and make
something of yourself and that is the
beautiful thing about the West look I
love your positive message right but
what about those times when I get very
annually when I do see like I just
showed before the break these absolute
idiots and by the way they usually are
young middle class Champaign socialists
from universities like Oxford uh
throwing paint all over the front of
Michael gove's office today because they
think they're making a point but
actually all they're doing is making
poor Working Class People have a really
miserable day because they have to clean
up after them you know that actually
makes me really angry because I think
that level of privilege and stupidity uh
is infuriating I agree with you and by
the way you know the more we've
interviewed people on trigonometry about
this issue The more I've come to realize
the workness is actually an anti-human
idea yes and that is why I talk so much
about climate change and it's not about
whether it's happening or not it's about
how are you going to fix that and the
problem we seem to have is because uh
wokeness you know the story goes
something like this we are evil people
and we must be punished and that's why
you get Net Zero and all this other
stuff and as I make the point in the
speech making poor pensioners die of
cold in Britain isn't going to fix the
climate right and so I agree with you
that there's a lot of things to be
annoyed about but I think we have to
start talking to young people and
remember they're young people they don't
know anything what did you know when you
were 20 what did I we have to start
engaging with them and challenging them
to be the problem is you think you know
everything
and because of the greater tunbergs of
this world because of woke people like
Nicholas sturgeon who I think are
actually taking advantage of 16 and 17
year olds are for her own political gain
and to advance her own very woke
political agenda actually these young
people are being empowered in a way that
maybe previous generations weren't I
agree with you I think the incentive
structures are there for them to be
victims I mean you were talking about
Harry and Megan earlier and we just had
David Starkey on the show we're going to
release the interview on Sunday and he
made the point that Harry has actually
done something very very good in his
life by starting the Invictus games do
you know what Invictus means in Latin
yes not victim yes and this is the
incredible thing so we do of course
you're right we live in the world talks
about that in his book actually how they
came up with the name and it's so ironic
given that the rest of the book is all
about how he's the biggest victim in the
world and so that is a very good example
of how victimhood is incentivized on our
society but I think the truth is as you
know full well Dan that's sort of
approach to life is not going to make
you happy and I think Harry is a very
good example of that so the message I
think to young people has got to be if
you want to fulfilled life if you want
to make something of yourself you have
the opportunity to do that and crying
about it isn't going to make things
better now it was a really brilliant
message I absolutely love the speech I
watch the full thing and I really
recommend that everyone does but I think
you've really hit the nail on the head
with Harry right pre-woke he did
something brilliant for the world the
Invictus games something that could have
been his legacy and maybe one day it
still will be and he seemed really happy
right he seemed like a really happy guy
post woke he's done nothing for them
maybe one day beautiful woman will do
that but indeed for now uh you know post
is woke agenda miserable yeah and all he
does is talk about being a victim rather
than helping the real victims of the
world and I think actually if young
people sort of look at those two Harry's
maybe they'll get an idea of why
sometimes you want to reject the work
ideology but I think you've done a very
good job to start that thanks for having
me back then great to see you
Constantine